let's have a think about all of this
let's have a look at some actual
examples of equations for motions so I'm
going to some point this we could have
call these the time equations I want to
think about the three quantities that
tell me everything about how an object
is moving in a kinematic sense and what
are those quantities in version 3
quantity okay very nice
displacement velocity and acceleration
okay so yes so if I say displacement
okay how will i define this there's a
variety of different things I can do it
so I'll start with a very simple case
first I just think I want to think about
this graph
okay this graph here now being you don't
have any markings for scale you don't
know what the frequency is you don't
know what the amplitude is so I need to
state this as generally as I can right
so what might an equation for that me
make it so I'm gonna have to have sign
in there but you don't know the
amplitude right the amplitude of this is
already one right do you agree so if I
want my amplitude to be anything I'll
just stick a sticker coefficient at the
front across the coefficient okay and
then what are you gonna have it here I
can't now for starters this is all in
terms of time that is the five equation
so there's going to be a te here
somewhere but you don't know the
frequency of this right - at the moment
the period of this particular mission
will be 2pi seconds minutes hours
whatever it is okay if I want to change
that how would I just the frequency of
no birth cost okay I need a new month
you close it in there now you'll notice
I've left a blank we're kind of done for
this particular one right I started the
origin that's the origin is my center
motion and that's it okay let me extend
this just a little bit I might not begin
at the origin I might have this
amplitude and this frequency but maybe I
start at say one of the extremes right
or maybe I start sort of
way through the motion okay to change
that that's really my graph backwards
and forwards and now we'll just change
my starting position so therefore I'm
going to introduce her face okay so this
is one example um clearly I could have
written this as cosine but there would
just be a different alpha yeah so I'm
going to not bother writing here because
you just gonna repeat all of this stuff
all right now despite my uh my dislike
of the notation generally speaking
because it's ambiguous and all that kind
of thing more easy to mistake for other
things because in this context you meet
this dot notation of what I'm gonna call
the velocity X dot okay when I
differentiate this is just chain rule
isn't it
your side turns into cosine that's your
outside function your MT plus alpha
contributes an N that's your inside
function okay so there's my velocity
functions and I want to go one more time
to the acceleration function this is a
tree great come on okay now here's
what's really interesting I want to have
a look at this last equation T because
very very important when you have a look
at this guy you notice that it is very
similar to what you write in fact just
to make it really obvious and lucky
don't do this with me if you take out a
factor of negative N squared all it gets
left behind is a sine M T plus alpha
which is exactly how we defined the
displacement function right so this in
fact is minus N squared X okay put a box
around that we this this is a pretty
cool result saying the simple harmonic
motion is um the deputy is defined by
them you know one a single sine function
or a single cosine function that's what
this looks like but really this is far
more informative this is farm
full moon I want you to come back to
these rubber bands again with me okay
what this is saying is that remembering
that we introduced in is just a constant
it's just the clinton that tells you
about the frequency the p.m. the period
of this thing if this is just a constant
then X double bar is some negative
number remember n is squared so it
wasn't so negative N squared must be a
negative number something you've done
that times X so these things are
proportional to each other to notice
thing and what does this mean physically
okay have a look here I've got my object
and it's moving away from the center of
motion okay so here's my left hand I go
with my finger up that's why I said
every motion here comes my my other
object over here actually let me put an
object in it I'm whiteboard marker is my
actual particle or whatever it is that's
moving okay as I move further and
further away from the center of motion
in a particular direction let's call
this negative direction okay cuz to the
left what does that tell me about the
acceleration when I'm right over here
the further you get away the bigger this
number gets right that means the bigger
the acceleration gets in which direction
the other direction right back towards
the center okay because if this number
is negative then the whole thing is
positive does that make sense okay so
what happens as you're going to hear at
a certain point namely beyond extreme
emotion okay that acceleration overcomes
your velocity okay so it's like oh I
stopped stopped stationary point station
right okay so you stop then you start to
come back okay now this point right here
this point right here when I'm sitting
on top of the origin okay what does this
equation here write which by the way
it's a differential equation it tells
this is the displacement is zero the
acceleration must also be zero yes so
there's nothing accelerating the object
in any direction at that particular
instant of time okay but just to rewind
remember where it came from it came from
over here so as it passes by the origin
it's going really fast to a really
really fast and that corresponds to the
fact that the steepest part of this
graph are at the center
question you notice that steepest
gradient it's moving the fastest okay
okay so then just to finish it off as
either you go past are now on the
positive side right so X is positive
which means acceleration news it's
negative which of course sends youth
back in the other direction and the
restoring force perpetuates the motion
does that make sense okay so this guy
here again remember when we had our
exponential growth indicator right and
we related the population with the rate
of the populations changed that was a
differential equation and that told you
what was going on this is the
differential equation for simple
harmonic motion okay this jarvan's
what's going on and a sine wave or a
cosine wave will satisfy this
differential equation now I want to
point out to you but I didn't bring a
bunch of these you have simple harmonic
motion on your reference sheet on the
extension one page naturally okay but
what they do is they extend this just a
little bit don't write this part down
but you remember when I gave you the
equations for population in temperature
whatever it is in exponential growth or
decay I gave you this remember that what
made it extension of one growth of the
CAG what sort of course that was the
only thing that was different was
constant right so for example something
like I don't know B plus will be minus
or any kind of combination of those okay
so we call this modify parameters okay
so this for instance if I had a negative
sign here it'll be a temperature that's
not going down as Europe it's going on
to whatever you like okay now I want you
to remember each of these had a
differential equation that came along
for the ride remember water was the
first one super easy it's just in this
case the K comes out front when you
differentiate and
you sleep on that but and this is one's
extension one the differential equation
for this one is to more complicated not
a huge amount what was it going to be do
you remember this okay cuz you
differentiate and you don't just get
back the same thing times a cluster
okay now you observe exactly the same
kind of normal situation versus modified
situation you exert exactly the same
thing here what kinds of things have we
taken into account so far we've taken
into account the extreme submission the
amplitude we've taken into account how
quickly this thing moves whether it's a
really slow oscillation or rapid one
we've taken care of when you begin to
start the origins you started an extreme
you start somewhere in between the one
thing that we haven't changed is on the
board for all the things that I've got
here the centre of motion is the origin
do you notice that okay your extremes of
motion might be negative a and a but
right in between them is always going to
be zero okay so how do I change the
center of version how do I change this
equation in exactly the same way that I
changed this equation it's just a
cluster okay so now you can write this
one again different centers versions
so these guys the center of mission is
just the origin but all you need to do
to make this move about you know instead
of x equals zero how x equals 1 or x
equals negative 50 or anything you like
is to say x equals was just shipped
there
you taught me be before so just go in
there okay now when we go back down and
we first see results right what's going
to be the difference between the
velocity function for this and the
velocity function for this will be the
difference there will be no difference
right because you'll differentiate this
constant is irrelevant right it's still
the same motion you just put it
somewhere else so it's still doing that
it's still fast when it's fast and slow
but it's slow so this will still be the
velocity function which means this will
still be the acceleration function right
but I can't do I can't do what I did
here
over here right again do you see you see
why I drew the parallel okay the same
thing is going to happen let me pick up
just by riding the Secretariat it's
gonna be this you pull out your factor
of negative N squared but at the same
time I don't want a sine NT plus alpha
here I actually want B plus a sine NT
plus alpha in there yeah so I'm going to
add it and then I'm going to subtract it
you're probably getting sick of this
time to break little trick by now right
so what you have inside the brackets he
is not X but X minus B does this look
familiar huh okay so same idea same
extension of this and what you'll find
now is that yes perfect that is exactly
what you find on the reference shape
they've written cosine instead of side
but it doesn't matter the only
difference between those as you notice
these alpha like which phase do you
choose that
to co-sign so let me put it like this
this guy here in this guy here with no
explanation because that's not what the
reference sheet is about those guys you
find on the reference sheet and to get
this from here you just think about your
center of motion not being B but for the
value of B being 0 that's it okay